and meanwhile folks the White House
putting the blame squarely on
Republicans for this crisis take a
listen
you had speaker McCarthy and the first
republicans in Congress who continuously
continuously take step to undermine what
is currently happening trying to
undermine getting border security we
would love to do this in a bipartisan
way but we're not seeing that we're
seeing what we're seeing from House
Republicans is wanting to defend defund
pardon me DHS
but a growing number of Republicans and
Democrats say that the blame belongs on
the president's policies here to discuss
Montana Republican Congressman Matt
Rosendale Congressman uh that's it's all
right good morning good morning uh let's
begin with uh we'll start with the with
the Press secretary's statement that
it's in it's your party that's been in
the way of all of this and you have
created this problem what do you say to
that
it's disappointing to hear those sound
bites coming out of the White House
Charles you know we don't have theories
we have actual examples of what to do to
secure our Southern border president
Trump did an outstanding job of it and
for the Democrat Party to cast stones
and dispersions against the Republicans
while they allow this humanitarian
crisis to take place it's disappointing
to me I mean not only do we have all
those problems at the border but far far
inland how it impacts every state
including Montana which is as far as you
can get away with the fentanyl deaths
and human trafficking it's disappointing
and that is the worst example of of the
problems with Washington D.C right there
that spokesperson Congressman for a long
time uh folks are saying exactly that
that in reality every state is a border
state when you see the amount of deaths
the death toll that's climbing the
ventinal death toll our population is
going down uh we are in a major major
crisis that Any Nation would sound the
alarm but now it really has come to the
doorstep you know of some of these
Sanctuary cities and I want to talk
about mayor Adams in New York Canada
Adams there's plenty of video of him
proudly saying we're Sanctuary City we
always will be everyone is welcome here
you know the whole read off the Colossus
poem from the foot of the Statue of
Liberty and now as the mayor the actual
mayor he's saying that this crisis is
going to destroy the greatest City the
most wealthy city in the world I mean
that's that's hard to to connect those
two things
it it truly is Charles I'll tell you I
was in the rules committee yesterday
afternoon unfortunately leader McCarthy
sent most of Congress home but there's
many of us that did stay here to get our
work done so that we can pass the 12
appropriation bills and in that
Committee hearing we heard Republicans
and Democrats alike having discussion
and debate and and homeland security has
won the appropriation bills we're trying
to pass now and so this was a major
subject and the thing is that if you
don't have repercussions uh the the
Democrats even agree with this if
there's not a hammer if there's not
repercussions if there's not
consequences to entering into our
country illegally you're going to
continue to see this vast flow of
humanity coming in we have to
re-implement those policies that we know
will work yeah I mean at least now you
won't get any sort of I don't think
you'll get calls that protecting your
borders is racist but certainly it
should be smart maybe we'll get
something out of my orcas on this next
visit uh coming up I want to switch
scares though because while all of this
is going down right you've got
negotiators still down on the hill
trying to hash out a budget deal
obviously everyone would like to avoid a
government shutdown which could happen
in just over a week now so far you're
not on board with some of the things
that have come up with short-term
funding uh so handicapped the likelihood
of a shutdown for us sure sure Charles I
I am so glad that you're the one who's
actually on here with me this morning
because you do have common sense you do
understand that we're going to collect
about five trillion dollars worth of
Revenue into the federal uh offers this
year but they're asking for seven
trillion dollars a year to be spent and
all of that will never be debated
responsibly and transparently unless we
are able to bring those 12 appropriation
bills up we've known that it's not a
mystery it's process started earlier
this year and and while these a lot of
folks are are focusing on trying to pass
a continuing resolution solution that
merely extends Nancy Pelosi's spending
levels and Joe Biden's policies some of
us are still here and we're saying we
want to pass these appropriation bills
and now that we have gotten to the the
time is is running out for one
government is fully funded through the
regular process they're trying to use
that as a tool to get us to submit to
the ways of old and Charles it doesn't
work we if we pass a continuing
resolution this Appropriations process
that we are that we are going through
right now to have open debate and
propose amendments and and transparently
and responsibly fund government that
process will stop yeah and unfortunately
that this is what it takes yeah you know
it's uh and of course you always get the
push back well this is not the time to
negotiate things like that but I always
wonder as a taxpayer when is the time
and we should note since they moved to
remove the debt ceiling uh not long ago
we've only added 1.6 trillion in
spending and we're at 33 trillion
dollars in accounting so America's
number one is something still that's
good Congress and Rosendale thank you
very much I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis